welcome back Aroma retail the sponsors
of this segment want to help make your
Valentine's Day fragrant Rocky spot stop
by there's smelly bar to learn how
Love is in the air at the smelly bar we
have everything you need to send your
space along with more than 90 different
fragrances any way you want to deploy it
and we're running this together this is
my husband
[Music]
we can offer you especially now that
we're coming up on Valentine's Day a lot
of the little smelly things that can uh
you know put you in touch with your
sweetie and get closer start by asking
yourself what scent reminds you of your
Valentine for example hello Noir is sexy
like me yeah and then we also have
fragrances that are beautiful like humor
and no matter what scent you choose
Aroma retail gift baskets are a great
way to help you diffuse love on
Valentine's Day and Beyond this is our
smallest one here and it has a lot of
goodies inside it says our wax candle
melter it has a set of our mix and match
it has oh it has the linen spray when
you want to freshen up maybe the bedroom
or the couch for Valentine's Day I think
it also has the four ounce bottles in
any fragrance you want yeah the four
ounce the four ounce bottles actually
refills our scent machine home Unit 101
which is also a great gift on its own
for scenting the whole home speaking of
our scent machines we also have our
little set machine travel fits in the
cup holder in your car it's got a
setting for car office or home where it
could run a lot or a little bit
depending on the size of space and it's
completely completely portable doesn't
have to be plugged in all the time on
the other side of the spectrum we've got
our set machine professional this is the
one that can connect to your ventilation
system or be freestanding but this
consent just about any space like we're
talking up to 10 000 square feet or of
course a smaller space and the oil lasts
a lot longer speaking of long lasting
Jim and Christina have been married for
14 years so Aroma retail knows a thing
or two about keeping the candle burning
you know these fragrances really they
set the mood we have we have a whole
mood collection where we focus on
different moods but most important to me
is just love it brought us together it
did our fragrances brought us together
in running this company but we also you
know we're constantly cognizant of what
scent should we run in the house this
month or whatever what do we want to
feel like absolutely because sense are
so important for our well-being and for
our moods for our happiness and and so
uh this could be the the gift that keeps
on giving and for whatever time then
Valentine's Day to uh to actually share
that with our loved ones
thank you Aroma retail for sponsoring
this segment for more information call
702-780-7370 or visit aromare.com they
have a special offer for you visit the
smelly bar and mention Channel 8 for 20.